this video is brought to you by Dollar
Shave Club Goku black if I was a point
to an aspect of Dragon Ball super people
would remember and argue over for many
years to come
it's this chilling nightmare of a tale
that plagued the timeline of future
tropes ruthless heartless and tenacious
this character as quickly and suddenly
as he appeared became a favorite in the
community however now years removed from
the conclusion of this arc I decided to
ask my followers a question on Twitter
that question the Goku black arc what
did you think the final tally saw with
almost 4,000 votes cast only 6% of
people actively disliked it however if
you look at the comments section for
longer than a second you'll notice a
trend the vast majority of comments
while positive almost always came with a
caveat mainly concerning its ending so
today I want to figure out what exactly
made the Goku black arc so enjoyable to
the majority highlight where I think it
might have gone wrong in places all the
while dissecting a character that has
widely become known as Dragon Ball super
best antagonists this is the narrative
nightmare and its Savior
Goku black
[Music]
in John troubies book the anatomy of
story he expresses that a story has a
minimum of seven key steps in its
progression from beginning to end this
is used specifically to achieve a sense
of flow clarity and pacing these seven
steps are weakness and need desire
opponent plan
battle self revelation and new
equilibrium and so with reference to
these seven general steps does the Goku
black arc work within them well let's
take a look the story opens with a back
it establishes three of the steps right
of the gate the opponent the desire and
establishes a plan for our hero as a
result the episode itself is fantastic
in a myriad of ways its pacing is
snapping the visuals match the tone and
themes of the arc and the audience is
given a goal many consider this to be
one of if not the best Dragon Ball super
episode capturing the audience's
attention immediately hooking them with
the final visual before cutting to black
specifically this was achieved through
establishing the desire of the story
immediately as author John Truby writes
desire is what your hero wants in the
story is particularly doesn't become
interesting to the audience until the
desire comes into play in the very first
episode in the very first scene of
desire the writers tell us without delay
what our hero desires he desires this
horrible shadowy figure to stop what
it's doing because of this immediate
vital piece of information coming to our
attention as an audience we now become
invested in the story immediately so if
this are kind of captivating opening
while ticking many boxes along the way
why do so many people have issues with
it after all was said and done well a
lot of people tend to focus on the
logical and technical incoherence within
the story's established time-travel
mechanics in other words they break the
story's established logic while time
travel was clunky and convoluted in the
cell arc it still technically made sense
however in the Goku Black arc it didn't
now to go into why it breaks its own
rules for time travel would be a
40-minute video into and of itself and
truthfully I think a story can still be
fantastic even if it breaks its own
internal logic occasionally so instead
of getting bogged down on that
I'd like to instead focus on the
narrative issues itself speaking of
which to understand why I think this
ending didn't work we need to look at
the final two steps of story structure
established earlier those being self
revelation and new equilibrium these
steps in layman's terms refer to the
hero better understanding and coming to
grips with who they really are as a
person and returning everything to
normal with one major difference the
hero has changed oftentimes this
revelation of self comes about due to
the pressure the opponent of the story
implements during a battle so where's
the problem well it's actually connected
to what made the first episode so
gripping they established the desire of
the story before everything else you
might have noticed that in the list of
seven key steps in story structure there
is one step before desire and that is
position number one for a reason in John
troubies book the anatomy of story he
writes writers who know that the story
doesn't galvanize the audience until the
hero's desire kicks in
sometimes get a little too smart for
their own good they think I'll just skip
the weakness and need step and start
with the desire they've just made a pact
with the devil
opening with desire gives your story a
quick start but it also kills the payoff
the ending of the story in other words
the weaknesses and needs of a character
are what make it possible for the
character to change at the end they are
what makes the audience care it enables
there to be a satisfying conclusion for
example in the 1991 horror thriller The
Silence of the Lambs the main character
Clarice is inexperienced and suffers
from haunting childhood memories on top
of living in a man's world this is her
weakness her need is to overcome the
ghosts of her past and to gain respect
as a professional in this male-dominated
area this comes full circle at the
film's conclusion as Clarice grows as a
professional overcoming her weakness and
achieves her desire to catch the serial
killer she is pursuing as a result a new
equilibrium is achieved she has
developed as a person
however Hannibal Lecter has escaped
additionally in order for the weakness a
need step to work the hero cannot be
aware of this defect he possessed
because if he is aware of it the story
is over the change in the character is
the story the hero should become aware
of this need right before the
self-revelation
after having gone through great pain and
struggle in this instance at the hands
of the villain near its conclusion in
the case of Future Trunks he doesn't
have a weakness or need that's
established really his need isn't that
he needs black gun that's his desire a
characters need in this context is
linked to his weakness and there isn't a
weakness that's established outside of
him not being strong enough or believing
that he and his time limb can handle it
which even if I was to assume that that
was his arc for this particular story it
happens to be the same arc he underwent
already during the cellar which
contradicts this quote by John troubie
he writes if he is cognizant of what he
needs the story is over and so because
this is Trump's his story and is clearly
showcased as a positive arc character
complete with early defeat and
inspirational speech before rising to
the occasion near the conclusion the
ending falls flat
I appreciate the speech trunks delivers
when pressured by fuse imasu is
inspiring but he is very much a positive
change our character with no change at
the very least no change he wouldn't
have otherwise been aware of prior to
put it simply this conclusion while
great to see trunks get the W is lacking
and falls short because there is no
meaningful change the character
undergoes to rise to the occasion and
save the day resulting in nonsensical
techniques miraculously being thrust
upon him without it being earned and a
needlessly tragic conclusion making the
entire journey pointless
[Music]
however with that said it doesn't change
the fact that only 6% dislike this
awkward voting so what made it work but
before I get into that I want to take a
second to thank Dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this video and for sending me
their five-dollar starter set to review
within this five dollar starter set I
was expecting to be sent a razor to my
house which I did get and they were
great quality but what I didn't expect
was to get four six blade razors a face
cleanser and a shave butter this shave
butter is a godsend because I genuinely
suffer from razor burn and dry skin this
genuinely made this problem disappear
and if that wasn't enough they deliver
right to your door so now on top of
getting great quality super affordable
razors I know don't have to keep using
the same blunt razor cartridges for
months because I keep forgetting to go
to the store and get a new one if any of
this might interest you or you'd like to
help out the channel check out the link
in the description and try it for
yourself it's only five dollars and you
get so much for it now back to the video
the concept of a character like Goku
black wouldn't have looked out of place
amidst a library of preteen anime fan
fiction however he was fantastic in
preparation for this video I put up a
second poll asking which of these was
your favorite dragon ball super
antagonist I included beerus hit jaren
and goku black as the options to choose
from and with four point four thousand
votes cast goku black won by a landslide
accumulating more than all the others
combined somehow did he work so
effectively he's a fantastic example of
what km Wyland author of creating
character arcs calls the negative
character arc the first in fact for
Dragon Ball but that's a topic so big it
requires its own video to briefly
explain what the negative character arc
is Cam Weiland writes the negative
change arc tells the story of a
character that ends in a worse place
than that in which he started just as in
a positive change arc the negative
change are hinges on the live the
character believes a terrific example of
a character that underwent a negative
change arc in pop culture is can see I
walk while being brainwashed and Men
related by the dark side of the force he
ultimately becomes Darth Vader this
negative change arc helped Goku blackens
imasu stand out amidst the crowd of
now-defunct and forgotten Dragon Ball
antagonists up to this point
Dragon Ball had been a trend of
utilizing villains that eventually
became good or were evil to the core
the masu and Goku black upset that trend
by becoming Dragon Balls first ever
villain to undergo a negative change are
on top of all of that Goku blackens masu
are clearly villains that were designed
to work perfectly within this particular
story specifically because they are
pursuing the same goal as the hero to
protect life however they have different
ideas of what it requires to achieve
this goal and thus conflict ensues as
John Truby writes if you give your hero
and opponent two separate goals each one
can get what they want without coming
into direct conflict and therefore you
have no story because Goku black and
trunks are pursuing the same goal this
creates a satisfying and organic reason
for trunks and black to come into
conflict and despite the admittedly
flawed but fond introduction to the
series it also delivered to us what I
consider to be the single greatest
character debut the entire series has
seen not just super the entire series
granted the arc itself had many glaring
flaws some of which I covered today but
to claim that the arc has no redeeming
qualities simply isn't a fair assessment
in my book thanks in no small part to
this character in an interview
discussing the Goku black arc itself
Akira Toriyama had this to say I put
together this story based on a
suggestion from the editorial office
like last time I write an outline of the
entire plot then the script writers
break it up into episodes expanding on
things changing things around and adding
in new bits as need be even I haven't
checked the final script yet there isn't
anything definitive to glean from this
quote specifically however if I was to
speculate I think there's a very good
chance that toy animation approached
Akira Toriyama to write a story about
trunks and an evil Goku specifically and
while not having any immediate plans for
trunks his character or how the story
might end
Toriyama might have written a rough
outline for this Dragon Balls story
without
many specifics considering how extremely
the arc in the manga deviated from the
animes interpretation using what I
imagined were the same notes from
accurate or yama should give indication
that the rough outline of events was
largely incomplete resulting in some
great takeaways and some terrible with
that said however these are my closing
thoughts samosa and Goku black have
etched their own identities into the
Dragon Ball mythos carving in a story
arc that has never before been seen or
appreciated in Dragonball through
dramatic and effective introductions
ruthless motivations and an intensely
desperate setting the arc was ambitious
and successful in enough areas to
alleviate its lackluster and deus ex
machina rich conclusion this arc has
many many problems some of which are
obvious and others maybe not so but what
is interesting is that despite all of
the arcs issues and shortcomings the
characters introduced and established in
this desperate tale possess enough
personality and charisma to persuade
even the most jaded viewers and readers
despite the at times incoherent nature
of its narrative the Goku black arc
reminds us that even the most confusing
and false film stories can still be
thrilling adventures full of tension
loss and catharsis as long as the
characters weaving the tail tell us in
an interesting way established within a
narrative nightmare
Goku black stands tall as wood of Dragon
Balls most memorable and impressive
villains thanks for watching
[Music]